this colorful spot has a dark past  las pamitas was once a dangerous place  with clashes between rival gangs  but the city government launched and  funded a project called pachuca paints  itself to turn the community around  the painting itself involved  participation from all of the households  they painted over 200 houses using 5 000  gallons of paint  these individually painted houses  combined to make one beautiful rainbow  design inspired by pachuca's nickname la  baya arosa or the beautiful breezy city  the aim of the project was to bring a  sense of liveliness and livability back  to the city  the ministry of planning and evaluation  of the city of pachuca has noted that  the crime rate in the city has decreased  since the mural was painted  you